- Welcome to this round table discussion,
on the 'Teaching Archive."
I'm Alice Kaplan.
I'm the director of the
Whitney Humanities Center.
And I will be moderating today.
Allow me to briefly introduce
our authors and participants.
First, Rachel Sagner Buurma,
teaches English literature
at Swarthmore College,
where she co-directs the
Aydelotte Foundation,
a center supporting
interdisciplinary liberal arts education.
Her work focuses on 18th and 19th century
literature and print culture,
the history of the novel,
20th century Anglo-American
literary criticism
and the history of higher education.
She's working on a book on
the social literary critical
origins of narrative omniscience,
and she has another book project
on how Victoria novelists
did their research.
Laura Heffernan teaches English literature
at the University of North Florida.
And her focus is 19th and
20th century literature
in culture, histories of reading
and histories of literary criticism.
She teaches courses on
the history of the novel,
modernist literature,
digital methods in literary study
and later periods of British literature.
She's currently serving as director
of UNF's Digital Humanities Institute.
Together, they have published
the "Teaching Archive,"
a groundbreaking approach
to literary history,
that takes us inside the classrooms
of major literary critics,
through their class notes and archives.
And what better time than now,
after this year of exile
from our own classrooms
to acknowledge the classroom
experience as a prime incubator
of critical thought.
Eye opening, paradigm shifting,
restorative, humbling,
all these words came to mind
as I was reading the "Teaching Archive."
We are, note that we are
putting a link to the book
with the University of Chicago Press
discount on the chat feature.
Rachel Sagner Buurma
and Laura Heffernan will be
joined today by Caleb Smith
professor of English and American studies
at Yale university,
who also teaches American literature
at MacDougall-Walker
Correctional Institution
through the Yale Prison
Education Initiative.
Caleb Smith's work
explores the contradictions
in American history between
Liberty and enslavement,
democracy and domination,
secularism and fanaticism.
And you can read a chapter
from his forthcoming book,
"Disciplines of Attention
in a Secular Age"
in critical inquiry.
Now I'd like to turn the
floor to Rachel and Laura,
who will give an overview
of "The Teaching Archive."
Caleb Smith will respond,
and then we will open
the floor to questions.
So please post your questions at any time
during the presentations in the Q and A,
and don't hesitate to use the chat
for your expressions of
interest and enthusiasm,
and for relevant bibliography.
Rachel and Laura.
- Alice, thank you so much
for that lovely introduction.
Can you see me okay?
Great.
And thanks to Diane and Sarah
and the rest of the Whitney
humanities stuff also.
Thanks also to Caleb for joining us today,
we're really looking forward
to our conversation with you.
So "The Teaching Archive"
recovers the everyday teaching
of literary scholars,
over the course of the 20th century,
in order to write a new history
for the discipline of English studies.
And this book really began
with our dissatisfaction
with existing approaches to
disciplinary history so far
and with the ways in which
disciplinary practice
get represented
and contemporary battles
over reading methods.
Existing disciplinary histories
tend to take a selective
and we think kind of distant
view of our profession.
We're thinking here of Gerald
Grass, professing literature,
or John Guillory's Cultural Capital,
to the extent that these
disciplinary history
has performed research on
art discipline history,
their research tends to
survey the disciplines
most self-conscious moments,
rather than it's kind of
practical everyday ones.
Traditional disciplinary history
and English studies tends to turn
to methodological manifestos,
and professional addresses,
mission statements and public feuds.
And it tends to produce
a sense of our past
that emphasizes innovation
and originality in a rupture,
rather than the everyday continuities,
that we think are more
familiar to everyday practice.
So for us, and we think for many others,
this produces a kind of alienating
and not so useful account
of our profession.
This method Wars are not
a good representation
of the everyday practices
of the discipline,
and the day-to-day work of it.
The longer continuities that
extended cost of our training,
and lead us together.
Disciplinary history is also,
we noticed tended to
ignore a really part of our
a really major part of
our professional lives,
of our classroom teaching.
There's been a tendency,
just a sort of default tendency to assume,
that English professors practice some form
of close reading in the classroom
no matter what they were
actually doing in their research.
And there's recurring
reference to just a small set
of pedagogical theoretical texts,
like Practical Criticism
or The Well Wrought Urn,
and textbooks,
like "Understanding
Poetry" books of Warren,
tend to stand in for the
real history of teaching.
So we decided what we wanted
to do is take a closer look
at what and how professors have taught,
by seeking out their teaching papers.
And so what we did do that
was come here to Yale first,
to The Beinecke ,
to look at Cleanth
Brooks' teaching papers.
We are curious to know whether
and how Brooks' classroom teaching
matched his account in
The Well Wrought Urn,
of how and why an English
professor should cultivate
students' appreciation for aesthetic form.
And the really unique thing
that we never found again
that we found in Brooks'
papers was a transcription
of his modern poetry class
from the early 1960s.
He had contracted with,
I think random house
to write a book based on those lectures.
And so he had employed a stenographer,
to transcribe every single thing,
the back and forth between
himself and the students,
even like the initial
chat at the beginning
of the class period.
And we never got to see that again.
After working on Brooks though,
we decided that we wanted to move outwards
and look at other kinds of institutions.
We were really curious to
know what teaching looks like
at the kinds of institutions
in which most people
who to go to college,
who go to college right?
I.e not Yale,
even though most disciplinary
histories tend to center
on elite institutions like Yale.
And Laura is gonna tell you
a little bit about the kinds
of places, the kinds of
different kinds of institutions,
where we went to look at classrooms.
- Yes, so we (audio drives
away the sound of the speaker).
So after we looked at
Brooks's papers at Yale,
we went to go look at J. Saunders Redding,
J. Saunders Redding archive,
his teaching papers
from Hampton University.
We looked at Caroline
Spurgeon's teaching papers
at Bedford Women's College
from the early 20th century.
We looked at T.S Eliot's papers
from the Worker's Educational
Association tutorial.
He taught, which we'll
talk about in a minute.
We looked at Alan Richardson's
teaching papers at Cambridge
and Edith Rickert's teaching papers
at University of Chicago.
We also looked at Simon J. Ortiz
and what he had taught at Marin College
in Northern California
and the University of New
Mexico and DNA college.
And we looked at Josephine
Miles, her teaching at Berkeley
we looked at Josefina
Niggli teaching drama
at Western Carolina college in the 1950s.
We actually looked at many more archives
then we ended up, including in the book.
And as we'll describe today
each of the places that we went
sort of required us to
develop a new approach
to our research,
and each place really taught
us something different.
So we'll start talking today
the first example we
will take you through is
T.S Eliot's modern English
literature tutorial,
which he taught here at
Sutton Grammar School
just outside of London
from 1916 through 1919.
So during world war one.
Eliot taught a couple of
extension courses in these years,
but he, the this course
was a course taught
through the University of London
but in partnership with
the Worker's Educational Association.
And so it was a three-year
tutorial course.
And one of the things we had to do
was go look at a bunch of
different WEA tutorial syllabi,
to kind of understand
the institutional values
of these particular extension courses.
So WEA syllabi reflected the fact
that these tutorials were meant to be
an exercising kind of deep equality.
Teachers were fellow students,
students were fellow teachers,
and they agreed to study
together for three years.
It was essentially a
community building exercise.
So communities decided what
courses they wanted to take,
and then once they had
embarked on a course
with a tutor of their choosing,
they would work together
to revise the course list
in years two and three of the syllabus.
By and large, these
students kind of rejected
the university's schemes
to kind of elevate the best among them,
to a place in the university.
For them the point was really
to extend study outside
of the seminar itself.
So WEA students often retaught
their classes to other community members.
They have held study groups,
including family members.
And the idea was that study
would create more study
rather than individual
achievement or accreditation.
And so when we looked at Eliot's syllabi,
it was really clear to us
that he learned how to adjust
his pedagogy to the WEA.
He made significant changes
between his first and his second year.
And then his second and his third year,
he responded to what the
students wanted to learn.
And he slowed down (chuckles).
This is probably familiar to those
of you who here are teachers,
he became much less ambitious
in what he thought he could cover,
in the second and third years.
And most notably,
he moved from a syllabus
that was organized
around the individual author,
to a syllabus that was
deeply interconnected,
and that brought back to life
the material working world
of Elizabethan writers.
So this had a practical purpose for him,
it helps students engage
in individual study
to follow up their particular interests
and to write seminar papers
that would then continue to be useful
and to connect back up with
class discussion in later weeks.
But it also sort of allowed the class to
reimagine these writers as
workers, as working writers.
You can see in the Elizabethan
Literature syllabus
I have up here,
he's teaching not an author based syllabus
but he's teaching popular
festival and religious rite.
In week one Renaissance Humanism,
the Elizabethan Stage,
students are learning
a lot about the context
in which these writers were working.
- And once you see how
Eliot adapted his teaching
to the values of the WEA,
to the workers education association
you can also see really dramatically,
how his classroom teaching
shaped his public writing.
So while Eliot was teaching his
Elizabethan Literature seminar,
he was also writing his
famous book of essays,
"The Sacred Wood,"
which if you don't know it as
a book really often credited
with changing literary tastes
in the Anglophone world of letters.
And it's something more spare and formal
and elites saying goodbye to Tennyson
and hello to Dryden and done.
"The Sacred Wood" includes essays
on figures like Marlow
and Massingir and Johnson,
whose plays Eliot had read
with his students in a seminar.
But the connections are
even much deeper than that.
Because what you really see in the idea
of literary tradition
that Eliot famously talks
about in "The Sacred Wood,"
is how the WEA impacted
Eliot sense of that tradition
and of literary value.
You really see in "The Sacred
Wood" a sense of writing
as important, not for its
singularity and originality,
but for the extent to which it makes
further writing possible.
So while most readings
of "The sacred Wood"
focus on literary tradition as elite
and Eliot's view of literary
tradition as an elite
and specialist,
once you see Eliot's
classroom, you really realize
that that view of literary
tradition is much more
about workaday writing
and the possibilities
of collective writing.
And then this was an
insight that we began to
see everywhere we looked,
after we realized this
about Eliot's classroom
sort of being inside and coded
inside "The Sacred Wood."
We realized that classrooms live inside
and have strongly shaped many, many
of the major works of criticism
that we read and teach.
So we realized, for example,
that Edmund Wilson's
historical interpretation
of literature essay
grew out of his varieties in
19th century criticism course
that he taught at Chicago in 1939.
We came to see that
Caroline Spurgeon's still
cited work "Shakespeare's
Imagery And What It Tells Us,"
that she published in the 1930s,
grew out of the art of reading course
that she taught at
Bedford College for Women
in the 19 teens.
And we saw how Simon Ortiz
had worked out the ideas
for his important essay
towards the National Indian
literature,
while he was revising his
native American Lit course
between 1976 and 1979 for
students at Marin college.
So we're gonna give another example
of how this happens.
- So the second example,
this is the course book list,
for Josephine Miles' English 1A course.
Miles was a poet and a professor.
She was the first woman tenured in
the English department at Berkeley.
And she taught a bunch
of different courses
in the department.
She taught a very popular
verse composition course,
she taught upper level seminars
and graduate seminars on the lyric,
and on 17th century poetry
and research methods.
But she most commonly taught English 1A
which was essentially the
first year writing course
at Berkeley.
And she taught it for over three decades.
You can see here, well
you maybe can't quite see
but the book list that she's jotted down
for her students includes a style guide,
a dictionary, also Virginia
Woolf's Mrs Dalloway,
a modern classic of their choosing
so they can choose Mann
or Proust or Joyce or Shaw, or O'Neil
a modern bestseller,
she says see a scrap lists,
Story Magazine, Poetry Magazine
Harper's, The Southern
Review, The New Yorker,
The New Republic and A Specialty Magazine.
Miles has every archive we want to
people keep their teaching
notes very differently,
Miles kept tons of teaching
notes on these tiny
pieces of notebook paper in tiny script.
And she did keep notes for
every semester of English 1A
that she taught,
and the notes really
testify to the fact that
it was a very workshop style course.
She said, in fact to the students
at the beginning of the fall, 1940 course,
she described it as a lab
or machine tool course
where the prof doesn't tell
and just watch his practice.
And she would often begin this course
with what she called the corner essay.
She would send students
out to a street corner,
usually the corner of Oxford
University in Berkeley.
And she'd asked them to
stand there for an hour,
and then write an essay about it.
And quite often the
students would give her
a first draft back,
that was simply a chronological report
of everything they'd seen
while they were standing
on the street corner.
And she would work with
them to revise the essays,
so that the essays would have perspective.
So that they would order a little bit more
the sense data that they had acquired,
give a little bit more of
a narrative or a story,
give meaning to what they had seen.
And that kind of work
of taking perspective
was something that Miles thought about
as beginning at the level of the sentence.
So the writer of a sentence
orders the elements in the
sentence through syntax,
through subordinating clauses,
connecting and prepositions.
And so Miles had students work
on sentences over and over in English 1A.
She had them write 50
words sentences together,
she had them choose a
sentence from a reading
and analyze its function
and its transition,
she had them write a sentence
that encapsulated a belief that they held.
And she you know
they worked every single day,
essentially on sentences.
- And this interest in language
at the level of the sentence
went alongside the quantitative
work Miles was doing
from the 1940s forward.
She was working with a big
Corpus of English poetry
to count the vocabulary of each era.
Trying to characterize the vocabulary
that poets had to work with as
sort of to hand it each era,
as phrasal or clausal is focused
either on adjectives basically or nouns.
If we could have table a from continuity
you can see some of her
results there up to the left.
So we realize while doing this work also
that Miles is one of
the foundational figures
and distant reading
and digital humanities.
In addition to the hand counted data
that dozens of monographs she published,
which she helped her graduate
students help her with
quite a lot.
In the 1940s, she also created
a computerized concordance
to the complete works of John Dryden.
She inherited this concordance
to John Dryden project
from a senior colleague
and ended up collaborating
with her graduate students
and with the women and the
Electrical Engineering department
at Berkeley, that ran the IBM machines.
So Roberto Busa, father
Busa is off really still
to this day known as the
"Father of Digital Humanities"
and a computationally
assisted literary study.
But Miles made her concordance of Dryden
far before he made his and really,
she is really we think one of the founders
of distant reading in
a way that Busa isn't.
And that's a kind of dramatic
like example of how looking
at teaching archives can
totally change the way we think
about the history of art discipline.
But in general,
looking at teaching archives
gives us a really new view
of a few different things,
which we're just going to
chat about very briefly
before we turn to our
conversation with Caleb
and with the rest of you.
Across all the archives in the
classroom that we looked at,
we see a really different
history of method broadly.
We see not a kind of contrapuntal
set of arguments played
out in publications,
but we see especially a longer
and more nuanced kind of historicism
is just an example.
But we also find a really different view
of who has made art discipline.
Because once you realize
that teachers have made
teachers of literature
have made art discipline,
you have a lot more
possibilities (chuckles)
for thinking about it's
fashioning and it's shaping.
Looking at The Teaching Archives
also has given us a really
different view of what has
been taught in the classroom.
So yes, canonical texts
and all of these archives,
but also a long, long tail
of less canonical texts,
and in fact, totally unliterary texts.
Maybe as much as half of
what's taught in classrooms
we think is not canonical at all.
So you still get Shakespeare,
you still get Mrs Dalloway,
but you also have all these other things.
And then the last thing
we wanted to touch on
the other thing that we saw
throughout these archives
is how closely teaching and research
and publication are intertwined,
and the way that we think they still are
for most practitioners today.
Despite the fact that the
modern research university
is really done its very
best to pull them apart.
So the very idea that we can have
teaching faculty or adjuncts,
like people who are academic workers,
who are not imagined as
doing research at all
as part of their job,
is a huge part of this obviously.
As our tenure process is and
all kinds of other mechanisms
but we think it's a real
testament to the strength
of the actual long history,
of teaching and research being intertwined
that so many of us continue to
experience them as connected.
Despite all these
administrative mechanisms
that make us pull them apart.
Laura, is there anything
else you want to say briefly?
- I think that's enough for now
- Okay.
So Caleb and Alice, I think you're gonna
Oh, sorry we're gonna turn over
to Caleb who's gonna speak a little
and then we're gonna talk with Caleb.
- Thanks Rachel and Laura
for that presentation
and for your fantastic book.
Thank you to Alice and
Whitney Humanity Center,
organizers and staff for inviting me
to be a part of this event.
I have a highest respect for
the rigor and intelligence
and thoughtfulness of this
book, "The Teaching Archive."
And I'm so excited to
be here to have a chance
to talk about it with you.
I just wanted to say a
little bit about the shape of
the book and what it means to me.
I'll say a little bit
about my own teaching
I'll mention one of our own.
Some teaching archives
that we have here at Yale.
And then I'll ask a few questions about
what I take to be some of
the kind of implications
of the book or the bigger arguments
that you've offered to us.
So this book brings to
teachers of English,
teachers of literature,
students of English literature,
some very basic questions
and very serious questions.
What is this discipline
of literary studies?
What are its origins?
How has it changed over the
past half century or century?
Who participates in it?
Who shapes its practices,
itself understanding?
What are its characteristics
theories, methods,
arguments, materials?
As Laura and Rachel have mentioned,
a number of histories of the
discipline have been written
and many of them tend
to follow more or less
by now familiar kind of arc.
They are histories of prevailing ideas
or in other words histories
of what English professors
have said about what
they're doing in their work.
And by their work they normally mean
their published scholarship.
I think it's probably true that
if you ask a number of English
professors about their work,
they'll take you to be asking about
their writing or about their scholarship.
Whereas if you ask them about their job,
they might take you to be asking
about their teaching and their service.
So those histories of the discipline
perhaps tend to focus on
influential books and articles
in which literary critics
explicitly reflect on their own practices
and the kind of debates of their time.
And this produces an
account of the history
the discipline that sort
of organizing around
some strong disagreements between camps,
philologists versus aesthetics,
historicists versus formalists,
multi-culturalists versus
the defenders of a cannon.
Those are some of the familiar
kind of patterns that emerge.
And then there's a kind of story
about a big change that happened
sometime around or after 1968,
when the discipline moves
from the era of the old new critics,
to a more diversified
and interdisciplinary enterprise,
that's drawing from traditions
and critical theory, cultural studies
area studies, ethnic
studies and other fields.
And here's where Laura and Rachel
in "The Teaching Archive"
make their big intervention,
they ask us to look not at
what literature have said
or how they've explicitly
described their project,
but instead look at
the materials that they
have produced as teachers,
the true history of English literary study
resides in classrooms they write
in one of their most
canonical moments maybe
in the introduction,
and maybe even more canonically.
Disciplinary historians of
English have by and large
declined to research in their field.
In other words, we won't
really know the history
of art discipline until
we've studied the history
of its teaching in the classrooms.
So the classroom as a
space of experimentation,
as a space of research, and creative work
not only the transmission of
knowledge from the teacher
to the student.
And here they argue against
the kind of separation of
teaching and research
in how the discipline
understands its own history.
And in how our work as well
is measured and assessed,
whether by each other
or by the universities,
or perhaps by a public.
I wanted to touch on
three kind of consequences
of this a methodological reorientation
of the history of art discipline.
One, what they show us is that
in practice literary studies
draws from many methods
mixing formal analysis with
historical contextualization,
mixing close reading
with ideology critique,
mixing thematic question and complicated
sort of computational techniques,
somewhat promiscuously.
And as Rachel and Laura mentioned in their
introductory remarks we would
probably find this to be true
if we were just reading
through the kind of
practical criticism of
any particular period.
And we certainly find
it in the classrooms.
And we find it less in kind
of method war situations
where people feel compelled
to align themselves
with one method or with one argument
or with one concept against
some opponent in a debate.
And so, Laura and Rachel
kinda teaching us how
not to separate those various
the kind of eclecticism of the discipline
out into those mutually
antagonistic camps.
Second, there's a kind of
historic graphic argument
about when and how the
era of close reading
or the era of the new
critics gave way to some time
of pluralism in the methods
and objects of literary study.
And then what "The Teaching
Archive" is showing us
is that it's not really
right to say that there is a
kind of post 1968 diversification,
particularly not a kind
of set of arguments
within elite institutions that then
radiates out and transforms the curricula
at other institutions across the country
or around the world world.
But instead that there were
many different kinds of
practices going on at many
different kinds of institutions
all along that, that kind of eclecticism
and diversity of theories
and methods is there.
If you go and look for it in
different kinds of classrooms.
Finally, maybe most
controversial literary study
a set of kind of ethical and
political arguments about
what happens when we value teaching?
When we value what
happens in the classroom
and how that might help us
to defend art discipline
in a time of crisis,
how it might help us to
see a kind of common cause
across a methodological differences,
and the sort of difference that
this new history might make
in this time of crisis in art discipline.
Where the question
some people might be asking is less
what is literary studies?
And more of what was literary studies?
I found this book to be an illumination,
and to resonate with my own experience
in teaching both in Yale
university classrooms
and in Prison classrooms.
Two kinds of institutions
that are sort of at the
margins of the big central
picture that Laura and Rachel
are drawing for us in
"The Teaching Archive."
And in those classrooms, I've found,
especially in teaching
across the two of them,
I've found how teaching with
different groups of students,
even with the same, more
or less the same syllabus
has really caused me
to reorient my sense of
what counts as remedial in one situation
and what feels advanced
in another situation.
Or what feels radical in
one situation versus feeling
conservative or even reactionary
in another situation.
And so, it does seem right to say
that the practical experience of teaching,
and working with students
in art discipline,
really kind of reorients
and destabilizes some of the
conventional and rigid
oppositions that we make
when we argue perhaps badly about
what it is that we're doing.
I wanted to show a couple of images.
These are not from my
own teaching archive,
but they are archival images held here
at Yale and the Beinecke.
This is James Weldon Johnson,
in his classroom at Fisk
University around 1933.
I show it partly because
we're all nostalgic,
and miss being in
classrooms with each other
and miss working with each other.
But also because as soon
as you see this image,
you see how it raises
such complicated questions
about the elitism and
anti-elitism about hierarchy,
and equality about
democratization and integration
in the context of Fisk
University in the 1930s.
My second image is from
Johnson's own teaching notes.
And this is a list of paper titles
of the papers that his
students wrote for the course.
I brought it to partly because
of the little cross out that
you'll see there on number six
which says comparison of something,
value of Douglas' for
different autobiographies.
This is a student's paper title.
And what comes before value's
originally written in as literary
and then it's crossed out
and the word historical
has been inserted there.
So that kind of interplay of the literary
and historical seems so kind of central
to Rachel and Laura's
arguments in the books,
and also raised for me what
would be an interesting question
about how the archival scholar
would deal with a kind of
with an instance like this,
where the archive presents
us with some ambiguity
that we have to resolve,
or some revision that we would
need to make some decisions
about what it's meaning was.
But the other reason that I
wanted to share this picture,
was just to give you the
sense of Johnson's sense
that an important thing
that his students were
working toward in that classroom,
was the writing of these papers.
In fact Johnson,
typed up this list of
papers and included it
the next time he taught this course,
as in part of the course description
to say this is the kind of
work that students would be
doing in his course.
So I wanted to close with
a couple of questions.
And these questions come
out of my own experience
as a teacher,
or come out of my own
experience as a researcher
in histories of discipline.
And are partly prompted by
some of what we've just seen
and the archival things
we've looked at together.
First I guess a question
about discipline itself
and how we value it.
One way to describe the project
of "The Teaching Archive."
I think, and Laura and Rachel can maybe
respond to this characterization is that
they have reoriented our
history of the discipline
of English or the discipline
of literary studies,
by bringing it within the
historiography of education.
In other words they're
writing a history of teaching,
they're writing history of classrooms.
That is its own discipline,
education and the history of education.
And it has its own interesting
kind of transformations
in the post 1968 period,
specifically a kind of critique
of a traditional liberal
account of the value
or the meaning of education
in public and otherwise.
There was in the post 1968
period that really kind of
radical critique of
educational institutions.
This is we can associate this with
full close work on knowledge and power,
but also major critiques by post-colonial,
and indigenous scholars,
who were thinking about the Alliance
between educational
institutions and politics
and forms of power that they
very much saw themselves in opposition to.
And so I wonder what that kind of account
of what a classroom is, might
do with and in conversation
with the kind of story that
Rachel and Laura are telling us
in "The Teaching Archive,"
which is so much a book about
reminding us or teaching
us again how to value,
what happens in classrooms,
how to value education
and its institutions
across different kinds of
social stratifications.
Along with that, I wanted
to raise a question
about the teaching of writing,
and the the Josephine Miles
example of English 1A,
really helps us to get there,
I think that's a place where
the book is really thinking
about the composition classroom.
There's one question I did
have in reading the text,
had to do with whether the
emphasis on literary studies
and reading,
how that fits in relation to
the kind of stratification
or division between the
teaching of literature,
and the teaching of writing?
Both of which might be
thought of as very integral
to the history of English as a discipline,
but which are increasingly
kind of separated
out from each other
and in hierarchized ways
within universities today.
In my own research,
and my own writing,
I've sometimes made an
argument that we need to
learn to see close reading
itself as a form of writing.
And I realized that a kind
of critique of that implicit
in 'The Teaching Archive" might be to say,
that I am doing the thing
that Laura and Rachel accused
disciplinary historians
and theorists of doing when they say
that we overemphasize
our published writing,
and under-emphasized what
happens in the classroom.
But as often felt to
me that thinking about
literary criticism,
about what's called reading
as a practice of writing,
can have the other effect as well.
That is, it links up with
the teaching of composition.
It links up with the teaching of writing,
and makes those things part
of a continuous practice
rather than insisting on
a division between them.
So I'd really be interested to hear,
and maybe I could just bring Laura
and Rachel and Alice all back on now.
And I present those to
you as open questions
and the starting points
for our conversation.
- Thank you Caleb.
And I'm encouraging people to
enter their intervention in the Q and A,
but meanwhile I'll pass
the floor to our authors
for some responses,
and I'll help with responses due to that.
Great intervention by Caleb.
- Yeah, thanks Caleb.
I mean, we could spend the last 20 minutes
just on one of these questions,
so maybe we'll try to
touch really briefly,
on them and make sure
we have time for others.
But yes, I mean, I think we
also see that full Codian turn
in literary studies too,
we have the same debate
about the history of the novel, right?
And how we're gonna,
I think the thing I'd
emphasize about our work,
is that we are trying to
value but not glamorize
or paint portraits of like great teachers,
but really just trying to think, not just,
but really trying to think more
about what practice looked like.
And I think that those
full Codian critiques
of education have still been real
and the disciplinary historic
works that do engage them,
have been really important to us.
I mean, the same thing that
people point out about Full code
and its uses is true for the (indistinct)
sort of the history
aggregate education turn,
which is that full code is
not saying you can undo that
those aspects of
institutions.(chuckles) Right?
And so, it's all we
think part of the history
of the discipline and that's
what we're trying to get at.
Laura would probably have
things to add to that?
- Yeah, I mean, I think,
when we started working on
this about 10 years ago,
I think there was a sense in
literary studies particularly
in the wake of Guillory's
Cultural Capital,
and conversations around that,
that there was, you know
Guillory is making an
argument essentially about
in the midst of the culture Wars,
about the contents of reading lists,
and suggesting that nearly adding,
minority authors onto reading lists
in order to make them more representative
kind of ignores the larger
function of the school itself
and in the reproduction of
homogeneity of hierarchies.
And that sort of left,
I think that left people
with a sense almost
that it didn't really
matter, what they taught,
in their classrooms.
And that this was,
it was easy for people to feel that way
because there already wasn't
much public conversation
beyond the culture Wars,
around common conversation
around classroom teaching.
And I think there was a tendency
to kind of have this all
or nothing fantasy about classrooms.
Like either classrooms
were sort of all powerful,
and reproductive or you could never hope
to accomplish anything
(laughs) in your classroom
that would extend down to the real world.
So I think it would, it begin,
we were really just
looking for something more
of a middle ground of
what it actually felt like
that some things failed,
something succeeded,
most things that were
happening were not entirely
under your control anyways.
And to sort of begin to develop
a vocabulary around that.
I think in response to
your second question
about the connection or
this kind of maybe break
between the teaching of composition
and the teaching of literature,
I will, you know,
you can definitely see the formation
of that discipline and the
growing split between them,
and the different labor
practices that ensue
around the teaching of composition
and the teaching of literature.
I will say the history of comp,
they have done a much better job
of historicizing their teaching.
They have really excellent
disciplinary histories.
They have a really good sense
of the kind of communal
property of their pedagogy.
And I think, in literary study,
the Miles' chapter is a
really good example of this.
There's just really
unrecognized genealogies
of literary study that emerged
from the teaching of writing
and the teaching of composition.
And I think given that
so many of us do both,
always have done both,
in terms of just our
graduate student TA ships.
And then what a lot of people's
jobs look like nowadays,
you know, we really haven't
well accounted I think
for that continual kind
of cross-pollinization
around those kinds of courses.
And then these upper
division English courses.
- If I could step in,
I was so moved because
of course I took English 1A at Berkeley,
(indistinct)
and I have a very vivid
memory of reading Lolita
in English 1A,
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and I also thought
it was incredible the way
Miles had them go stand on
a street corner in Berkeley,
because it's the exact method of
the avant-garde French literary
movement, "the Oulipo."
I mean, Josh paddock who set himself up
on the plus sensory piece
to observe the totally Beno,
you know, for hours and hours.
And she sounds like an artist.
I mean, she was hat.
It's almost like pre situationism
like she was having them do.
And I don't know if she was aware of that,
but it's a fantastic exercise
in documentary writing that she was doing.
That was one comment.
And my other comment is about teaching
composition versus teaching literature.
The equivalent of that in the
National Literature's of course,
is teaching beginning language
versus teaching the great works.
And so I think those of us
in the National Literature's,
we all started as teachers
teaching elementary grammar.
Which is even more of a distinction
than teaching writing and
teaching English literature.
And I've always thought that
we have very different styles
because of that as teachers.
Because we start out learning
that what you do is listen.
So it does really change
the authority dynamic
in the classroom.
You just, 'case you have.
These are more like comments
than questions for you
but I wonder if it evokes
something for all of you.
- Yeah that's illuminating.
Cause it hadn't occurred to me
but it's also true that
it's kind of almost
closer to what Miles is doing.
The idea of teaching
at the level of grammar
(chuckles)
and language than assuming
that our students already know
the structure of the sentence,
the structure of a paragraph.
It is more like language learning.
- Yeah, Caleb.
- Yeah that's also true.
You would find that in
the James Weldon Johnson
teaching archive as well
that his introductory course
was a language and literature course,
although it's in the English department,
but has a good deal of grammar
and vocabulary built into
the literary reading that they're doing.
- We've got a couple questions.
Here's one, somebody who
values immensely the turn
of the everyday practice
of the discipline rather
than its manifesto statements
or public quarrels,
but wonders how you make the
bridge from that oral place
in context, specific
location of the classroom
to the public published
and circulated domain
of written criticism,
which has its own overlook
everyday practices of written style.
- Yeah, that's a good point.
I mean, there's really interesting
recent work by Jonathan.
Kramnick on exactly this topic,
on how the every day the
kind of real practical,
continuous work of published
criticism and literary studies
focuses on, like anybody
goes inline quotation,
just studying the
incorporation of the texts
that you're looking at
into your own language.
- I think, yeah.
I mean, we try to make them,
when we say that we're
able to see classrooms
kind of present within works of criticism
with a major works of criticism.
We said that in that
kind of brief form here
but we can expand on that
a little bit I think.
Even with the example of the Eliot
and you know I think one of
the things we notice is that,
there's sort of ethos of the classroom
that play specific role and very
communal scene of valuing
literature does get worked up
in places like "The Sacred Wood"
or in even in Miles' work
on poetry rather than poems
into a kind of vision
of literary tradition
that is very populous
that is populated by what Eliot calls
"second order minds,"
critics, translators,
writers of para text.
And so, there is I think a
sense that when you pivot to
the writing of criticism,
you're sort of doing it
stepping out of the classroom
with more of a sense of
how many hands are involved
in the creation of a
piece of published writing
and in the eventual reception of it,
and hopefully the longer trajectories
that it makes possible, right?
By making other kinds of writing possible.
So that was something
in stepping in for us
and moving from this classroom scene
to people's published scholarship,
we started to pay
attention to these ways of
thinking about literary
tradition, literary value,
and the practice of writing that seemed
more populous and communal
than we'd been (indistinct)
- You know, completely
deconstruct all our mythology
about the new criticism.
You completely redo our
sense of the new criticism.
I'm not like,
I mean, my generation came
up with the sacred mission
of fighting the new criticism
and all it's elitist as in
close reading only assumption.
So reading about Eliot,
and it's just, it's quite astonishing.
Yeah.
- I think that is, I mean,
I think in critiquing the new
criticism and another things
there has been a tendency
to make it more unified,
to make it bigger than it in
fact was, or more coherent
or more dominant even.
So I feel like too, this book
kind of comes after a wave
of critique that sort of
ended up making many things
a much bigger deal
than they perhaps were
in the first instance
- Another Question?
Oh, sorry Caleb did you
want to say something
before I move to the next question?
- Yeah, I mean, I just,
I wanted to pick up on Laura's phrase
like what kind of writing is possible,
cause that sort of how I
think about a method Wars
in a way like,
it's so obviously wrong that,
you know, that the political
economy of our profession
is in decline because of
too much ideology critique,
(laughs)
for the political economy of
our profession is in decline
because we don't love literature
or something like that.
So obviously wrong, but it makes
me want to ask the question
like what's being enabled by this mistake.
what are people getting from
getting it wrong in this way?
And I think it, that they
get to treat a problem
with political economy,
as if it were the kind of problem
that they know how to
address in their writing.
As if it were an intellectual problem,
as if it were a misreading,
as if it were a conceptual mistake.
And that could be addressed
therefore argumentation,
through the kinds of skills
that they know how to have,
and through the kinds of disagreements
that we know how to have
with each other in public,
rather than through a
work of a different kind,
which would have to do with organizing
and the transformation of
institutional structures
and economic circumstances.
And in that way, I mean, I do think that,
offering a new history is
a little more continuous
than totally distinct
from that particular move.
That if we see this different history,
I think we can do is
write a history, right?
I think we can do as Scott
specifically in our role
as a scholar is write a
history and change the history.
And maybe that history
can, I hope it will,
I think it is,
changing our understanding
of the value of what we do,
but it's another step
to transforming that
political economy obviously.
- Yeah, we talked about this a
little bit in our conclusion,
but we hope I think part
of what this history does
is make the work of teaching
more clearly, right?
Like part of all the work that we're doing
in higher education
and not separated from like our work
which is our research that
we also like to think of
and which is labor.
And so we kind of,
I completely agree with your
diagnosis of method wars.
It's like we're trying to domesticate them
into something we can solve,
within the English department.
And that's just clearly,
(chuckles)
that's a tragic, tragic mistake
but we do hope in some way that
there's work that you can do
in the discipline to think
about labor in a nuanced
and granular way that
might help the problem.
- It's blow to alienation
and division school.
Let me go on with questions.
We've now suddenly got a lot of
really interesting questions.
This one is about teaching
online during the pandemic
but also in general,
on what your work tells
you about the growth
of online teaching generally
versus face-to-face classroom,
especially the growth of online teaching
in community colleges.
And what do you see happening
in the classrooms and the courses?
(laughs)
- No, No, It's, I mean, yeah,
I think, you know, we,
I think many of universities were already
beginning to go online
before the pandemic,
particularly in the asynchronous mode.
I did training to do
that at my university.
There was a lot of incentive,
financial incentive for professors
to move teaching online.
And one thing I noticed
in the training is that
you're very you know,
they're telling you essentially
to leave out anything
remotely resembling kind of
scholarly expertise.
(chuckles)
Like it's like sort of,
you have to really like kind of,
give people the three
minute recorded video
no longer than this and so on.
And it hasn't been my experience
that that's necessarily
what students want or
are capable of receiving.
So I do think that there's,
we talk a fair bit.
And then just the conclusion
to the book about,
some of the ways in which in
the modern research university
there is a whole industry
built up now around
telling professors how to teach, right?
And giving them advice about teaching.
- Yeah, Centers for teaching
and learning all over,
but also visits somebody.
Another interesting
question on the chat is
what about evaluation of
teaching by colleagues
in the course of a tenure
review or a promotion review?
How does that work?
- Yeah.
- I mean, are we capable of
I'm just imagining an
extension of this question.
Are we capable of evaluating
someone's teaching
without understanding this larger history,
and seeing one person's
classroom in the context
of all these decisions that
teachers have made over time?
- Right, I like the idea
that this can help having a
deeper sense of the history,
could help a more professional
and contextualized,
disciplinarily contextualized
evaluation of teaching.
It's interesting because so
when people do look at classrooms
especially the earlier classrooms,
that we've looked at
in scholarly research,
they tend to only look at
the teaching evaluation.
So there is this whole
kind of interesting history
of teaching evaluations
being used to stand in
for classrooms.
The way I think they very much are
in tenure decisions in which
anyone cares at all about them.
- It's funny, there's this
rumor going on in Europe
that Americans are given
grades by their students
and they're really appalled by it.
(laughs)
- It's sort of true, yeah.
- I've got one.
I think we have time
for one more question.
Did you sense that there's some connection
between teaching strategies
and research methods
but also literary production?
I mean, do some people's
way of teaching actually
feed right in it?
Sounds like it's true of Eliot,
but other examples of the
way that teaching inspires
literary production.
Now I take it that means not
just critical production,
but the production of literary works.
Maybe fiction or,
- Yeah, absolutely.
I think probably the best
example of this in the book
is J. Saunders Redding,
who is teaching you know,
he's teaching at Hampton
and the '30s, '40s and '50s,
courses like Negro and American Literature
but also courses on the novel.
And he's also writing,
in a couple of different
genres that are realist.
So he's writing a documentary,
he's writing a campus novel,
and he sort of writing all
around this kind of question
of realist representation,
as he is teaching in the classroom.
So he's teaching Dickens,
thinking about how Dickens's autobiography
gets written into some of his fiction,
at the same time that he's
kind of writing all around
that matrix as well.
So that was a good example
of where we really needed
to look at the fiction and
the literary production
in order to understand what
he was doing in the classroom.
- Yeah.
It's fascinating that you
mentioned the campus novel,
because it is a genre that's just exploded
over the last 30 years.
So there is something fascinating
about the scene of teaching
that appeals to novelists.
And all those campus
novels are not realist.
I mean, some of them are just wild.
(laughs)
- I guess the obvious,
I mean the obvious thing
there is a lecture courses
that get basically kind of
collated to become books often
kind of introductory
books in various fields.
But the question about
online teaching definitely
reminded me that last semester I recorded
my lectures as audio lectures
and never as teaching felt
more to me like writing
than it did then.
Because it was gonna be recorded.
I found I can't do this,
I can't sort of stand in
front of the room and vamp,
and look at a picture together,
and interact with the students.
And because they could
play it back and so on.
I felt almost a level of
like writing for publication.
Like each word has to
be precise in its way.
And I think there's
probably a ton of examples
of places where we could
find some student question,
or student response to the lecture,
or even the shape of a lecture
course that ended up changing
that person's book that was based
on the lecture course that they gave.
- Somebody once told
me that when you teach
you just never know
what of all the stuff you say
is gonna stay in the
minds of your students.
Like some, don't you
remember some just weird
anecdote that some teacher
told about their dog,
and you've forgotten the
whole rest of the chorus
but you remember one anecdote.
(laughs)
- Absolutely.
- All right (indistinct)
I'm ending on a little
light note here but I just,
I want to thank you all so, so much
for this conversation,
that was really, really fun,
and inspiring and thank
you to all the participants
for their questions.
We'll go look on the chat
too, to see your comments
now that we're done with the Q and A.
So thank you all
- Go get this book you all
and read it.
(chuckles)
- And please, we are gonna put the link
with university of Chicago
Press discount code.
We're putting it in the chat.
- Thank you so much, Alice.
And thank you, Caleb.
- Thank you.
- Thanks Alice and Caleb.